this is huge in the upcoming Toy Story 4
in that call you play that that's what
man your achievement and it kind of hits
me in waves like at first when they
asked me I was like oh this is nice and
then when I hear my voice in the trailer
it's like oh crap this is really
happening but I play four key four key
he's a spork who's having a bit of an
existential crisis I think we have a
pick there sport he right there you know
what you wouldn't have swing it you
wouldn't have had to told me that tell
me that that was you I would be stupid
like well Tony Hales gonna place four
key I know but he's so sweet it's so I
got I was able to see a screening of it
and it's such a great movie yeah it's so
so sweet but also when you're in one of
those movies you know what's going to
endure for a long time you don't I mean
there's such a plan it's beautiful I
mean it's like what Pixar can do in the
animation and I mean Bo Peep is in this
one a lot and just what they've done
with her face because she's a china doll
I think what they did with lighting it's
really pretty fantastic you also got to
speak in animation you got to play the
Joker in an animated battlers movie and
the thing that I thought was fun is that
you so often have to play get to play
and you play it so well but you play
these characters they're just sort of on
defense on the defensive you do it in VP
do it an Arrested Development's sort of
trying not to offend trying and in you
gotta you got to play the Joker you got
to be evil yeah I was thinking that must
have been was that like a charge for you
it was a church you know cuz it's you
know I don't get to play that much and
it's just I mean it you're in a voice
booth and you can you know talk like
this and he's very creepy and and
cynical and that's that's funny too
because you know Buster blesses her you
know he you're right he was just kind of
always in his hole even his body was on
the defense the whole time like he put
his hands back in his chin it was like
he was always like you know what's
coming at me yeah I remember Mitch
Hurwitz saying to me cuz I was like what
is you know what does Buster want life
and he would always say safety yeah
that's all you want yes and they're not
veep obviously it's the same thing where
Julia Louie Dreyfus is constantly
leaning into you and you can tort your
body it's hilarious it seems you two
have together
she leaned and he leaned backwards yes
hilarious and I love cuz Gary all now
all Gary wants is like he just wants
Selina to love him but the best thing is
if Gary could he would just like cut two
feet off of his legs to be below her he
hates to be above her right so he's
always he's always hunched just trying
to get below her